alors elle encore j'ai six millions
personnes qui me suivent tué influence
yeuse j'aimerais montrer vraiment qui je
suis je reviens de très loin d'eux a été
mise en examen j'avais 20 ans on disait
que j'étais bête
aujourd'hui j'ai ma marque cosmétique
est monté un empire j'ai mon trentaine
d'employés de 8 ans comptait encore
un père exceptionnel le père que
j'aurais aimé avoir mon père c'est mon
talon d'achille alors
voulez vous épousez naville à la chieuse
au grand coeur oui
pour moi la vraie vie c'est ma famille
ça me permet d'avoir plein d'énergie
pour la suite
c'est je vais essayer de lui faire la
plus belle robe qu'elle puisse rêver la
robe et enfiler et maintenant vous
n'avez plus de regarder j'imagine mon
père et moi en train de descendre les
marches j'espère vraiment que ça va se
réaliser
j'ai pas eu un retour de touba c'est
vachement stressant quand même